- [Instructor] We're told each big square
below represents one whole.
Express the shaded area
as both a mixed number and a decimal.
So pause this video and
see if you can do that.
What would this be as a mixed number,
and then what would it be as a decimal?
All right, now let's do it together.
So let's first start
with the mixed number.
So we see that we have one whole here,
the whole thing is filled out,
so this is going to be one whole,
and then over here, we have part
of this second whole filled out,
and it looks like we're dividing
this whole into 10 equal sections,
and then two of those are filled out.
So as a mixed number, we have one
and then you have two
of the 10ths filled out.
So this is gonna be 1
2/10, and we're done.
You can see here, this
is split into 10ths,
and we filled in two of them.
Now, what about as a decimal?
Well, we could just express
1 2/10 as a decimal.
We could say, hey, that's going to be one,
and then we get to the 10th place,
and then how many 10ths do we have?
We have two of them.
So that's going to be 1.2.
Let's do another example.
So here, this is a
little bit more involved.
They say, once again, each big square
below represents one whole.
And once again, they want us
to express the shaded area as
both a fraction and a decimal.
So pause this video and have a go at this.
All right, so let's start
with the fraction again.
So we have one whole, two wholes,
and then partially shaded
in this third whole,
so if I'm gonna express
this as a fraction,
really it's going to be a mixed number,
I would say that this over
here, this is two wholes.
Now, this third whole is
only partially filled in,
and we can see that it has
been divided into 100ths,
you can see it's a 10 by 10 grid,
so each of these squares
represent 100th of a whole,
and how many of these
100ths are filled in?
Well, let's see, you have
10, 20, 30, 40, 50, 60, 70,
and then you have 71, two, three, four.
We can see that 74 of
the 100ths are filled in.
So as a mixed number, this
whole thing would represent 2 74/100.
Now, if we wanna write it as a decimal,
we would have two wholes,
and then we could go to the 10ths place.
You could just write two
and 74 100ths like that,
if you're pretty familiar with it.
You could also think about it
in terms of how many 10ths and
how many 100ths did you have.
We have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven 10ths,
and then we have four
more 100ths beyond that,
so you could think of it as
74 100ths or 7/10 and 400ths,
but either way, we are done.